welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and if you've seen the
Marvels then you'll know it teases a big
thing with the ending though the movies
getting mixed reviews I actually think
the final few scenes might tease
something major coming down the line not
not Jonathan major something else or War
of the Worlds have pits two franchises
against each other throughout this video
I'm going to be going through that big
scene and giving my few time on what I
think is going to happen heavy spoilers
ahead and if you don't want anything
ruined then I highly recommend that you
turn off now please hit the thumbs up
button and if you enjoy the video make
sure you subscribe to never miss a
breakdown just laughing cuz every time I
say ruined someone takes the mick out of
it in the comments but I won't get mad
at you thank you for clicking the video
now let's get into the Marvel's post
credit
scene she tore a hole in
space there's a different
reality leading into
ours so the movie ends with an incursion
bringing two realities hurtling towards
each other faced with no other option
Monica ends up flying into the other
side to help close the barrier from here
she gets stuck on the other side which
leads to meeting some familiar faces I
feel like this was kind of an act of
desperation and Kevin fagy was just
like go get the X-Men Marvel's
popularity has kind of waned in the past
however this is the trump card that
everyone just wants to get to so yeah
I'm kind of glad that they pulled it all
out here just when I thought I was out
they pull me back in now Incans are a
major thing that pulls from the comics
and if the Worlds Collide then the
entire universe is destroyed this is
because we learned there was a higher
power known as the beunders that had
placed a molecule man into every single
Universe this was someone who was the
same across all realities un thus he
could act as a multiversal bomb to
destroy the Multiverse all at once
setting him off with then wipe out all
existence but then someone else came
into the prey that was none other than
Dr Doom who'd formed a religion around
himself with his followers the black
swans these swans would then travel
through every reality and wipe out the
molecule man so that he couldn't be
detonated now this in itself had a
domino effect where it started off the
incursions that sent the worlds towards
each other here though incursions they
work slightly differently with them
being caused by someone dream walking
into another reality I also think a
person's presence there might cause
things to set off which is why in the
spiderverse we had something similar
with 2099 going into an alternate
universe at the end of Multiverse of
Madness Christine also warns strange
about staying too long in an alternate
reality and thus I think it's mainly
tired of someone's presence either way
darb Ben's what brings these worlds
together and this is caused by her
opening up portals that destabilize
reality we close out with Monica being
trapped in one of these and at these
Point she wakes up in a hospital bed
this looks like a sleek and futuristic
room which I think is the first clue
about where this actually is now we
never get a confirm that this is the a38
but I have my own theories about why
this could be either way it looks like
like the basement and Xavier's School
for gifted youngsters and the tech also
seems like it's pulling from the 838 now
they had that due to their civilization
not suffering the snap and in that
Universe they managed to stop Thanos and
thus they had five years on the 616 here
Maria's also at her bedside which is
sort of a flip on what happened during
one division in the show we know that
monik had been at a bedside which is
when the snap happened across that
entire universe this would be when she
last saw her mother and now it's coming
full circle from that exact moment
Maria doesn't know who she is though and
this is because this one clearly took
them on a path in which they didn't have
a daughter and that was because she got
to the hanger first and we've seen
flashbacks how she never wanted to be
Captain Marvel Maria has been placed on
this path though and th she sort of got
forced into a life she wouldn't have
chosen if she'd had Monica as we
discover Maria's also superpowered here
which is akin to the 838 again this
being that Universe never gets confirmed
but I think the little things that
happened here actually show that it's
the case firstly Maria was Captain
Marvel in there and I don't know how
many other universes that that would be
the case secondly we have to look at the
old plot leaks and see what they
describe this universe as they to said
that this was the a3a and that Maria
survived her encounter with W she of
course also had Captain Marvel's powers
and we've seen in the films how strong
this makes Carol girl got headbutted
Fallen by Thanos and didn't even
flinched and yeah very very strong
thus I think the rubble falling on her
that just knocked her out and since then
she's went to the next level the costume
here highly resembles binaries and she
also gets referred by that name too
binary is basically The Next Step Up
from Captain Marvel and her getting beat
like this could have made her go that
route which would explain why she's had
the costume change on top of that
there's also Beast who's fully CGI let's
go baby he looks exactly like how he did
in the comics and cartoons with a man
even rocking little spectacles once more
he's voiced by Kelsey grma and this
could show the way that they're going to
be taking things now in case you don't
know the comics had a group known as the
Illuminati the Illuminati the Illuminati
who are basically a secret society that
control world events amongst the members
was Professor X but eventually he ended
up being killed in Death Beast took up
the position which could also explain
why does he's here the a38 of course had
its own Illuminati and on top of that
Professor X was killed like man legit
got his face torn apart however as Beast
mentions he's going to go and inform
Charles which might might negate our 838
Theory as we know though Professor X has
died more times than Kenny and he's been
brought back to life multiple times
whether it's the Last Stand in which he
was teased in a post credit scene or
whatever the man keeps coming back and
yeah he he can't be killed this is
because the guy can actually transport
his mind at the moment of death and thus
inhabit another body and just keep
living now he might still be part of the
Illuminati however due to their numbers
being so low they might have recruited
other members that could be beast and
again I think this is the world we
visited before and that it could be
setting up things for where we're going
to go now in the comics after all the
incursions Whittle down the worlds we
were left with just a 616 in the
Ultimate Universe these two ended up
going head-to-head which culminated in
both Earths then being destroyed Dr Doom
then brought fragments of every world
together and he created something that
was known as battle world and that's
skipping ahead and instead what I think
we're heading towards is the idea of Two
Worlds Jing it out if one world's made
up of mainly X-Men then that could lead
into them fighting the Avengers this
could play off in Avent versus X-Men
that's one of my favorite runs in the
entire Marvel history and that was a big
whole thing on its own that was about
stopping the essence of the Phoenix The
Avengers wanted to stop it dead in its
tracks Ras the mutant saw being as a way
to save their race instead with this I
think we could have basically what to
play in the ultimates versus the 616 and
use the basis of their survival to
Kickstart this conflict one of my
favorite stories in the comics and
movies is also Civil War and I love the
idea of Heroes going against each other
when when you think about it the 616
also drew first blood because W wiped
out their version of The Avengers thus
they're probably going to be afraid of
that Universe because it's left them
without that Earth's Mightiest Heroes so
you can see how they'd be wary of this
world and likely at most points have
their fingers on the trigger now why I
think this is the best way to go is
because these are characters that we
already care about Game of Thrones yeah
Game of Thrones what they did
brilliantly was build up every character
throughout their Seasons when they came
down to it and they had to fight each
other you were gripped her out because
you didn't know who you wanted to win so
the way that Marvel could go about it is
eventually they hit the Avengers versus
X-men storyline with the L team being
made up of new faces however I think the
best way to take it would to be of
course to go with characters that we
already know in love imagine Kelsey gr's
Beast going against Hulk or something
someone like maybe even Wolverine facing
off against him Q Jackman yeah you'd
kind of be rooting for him but you'd
also have that attachment to Mark
Ruffalo as well what you mean you hate
him and you want Hugh Jackman to
absolutely obliterate him to me it would
just make the battles more impactful and
actually give them Stakes if it was two
characters were attached to facing off
against each other this is something I
feel works really well in Civil War and
it's one of the main reasons that that
movie pops so much sh the airport scene
you know everyone's holding back and
they all kind of make jokes about
fighting with each other whe come that
final fight with Tony versus cap you
know that that battle could actually go
either way Tony of course discovers his
mother was killed by Bucky and all that
holding back's now gone out the silo
Maria being there for Monica could add
some interesting Dynamics too because
you got someone whose mother died before
they got to say goodbye this is a
reality in which he's still alive and
thus they could add something in where
she's desperate to be with her Monica
could really struggle with weather to
help to destroy this world as in doing
so she's going to kill this version of
her mother it could really add some
complexities to it and make it so the
MCU has some Shades of Gray that it's
solely been missing for a while now I
think just having these two teams go up
against each other could also add to the
complexities that we have in the comics
for example in the wake of AVX Captain
America became part of the Illuminati
however when the incursions happened
they realized he wasn't willing to
destroy other worlds and thus they
erased his memory eventually C found out
and went to war with the Illuminati who
were then forced to go out into hiding
and these sorts of things could be
adapted into a really great story I
think and honestly I kind of hope we get
something like this before Secret Wars
that could then have both worlds being
destroyed and then battle world gets
stuck with two sides that now have to
work together this Earth could also
potentially be where Dr Doom's based out
and maybe even the Fantastic Four
characters Reed unfortunately he got
turned to Mom's spaghetti like it was
the 838 mile but the other members of
the team could then be brought across
another Reid could then be brought into
battle world as in secret Wars he was
also thought to be dead Reed emerged at
the end to then stop this doom and
though it's going to be Kang Focus there
is a lot they can do with it so yeah
lots of different ways I think they
could be taking things and obviously let
me know your theories in the comments
below it's also that Young Avengers film
that's teased 2 and I'm guessing that
we'll get an announcement for it shortly
might not even be the a3a and that could
be a reach but I think some of the
things I've talked about here could hint
at that being the case I would
definitely love to see an Avengers
versus xman movie and this could be
built upon further in Deadpool 3 as we
know that's two setting them up and du
this score here it could even be the
main X2 timeline the score for that
film's also used at the end here and
Deadpool's also basically in that
Universe I don't I don't know if
definite if that's the case cuz the
timeline's all over the place but
personally I think it's better to go
with the universe where we already know
the characters and instead of having two
superp powered maras we just have that
one who survived don't know the more
variant of characters I see that have
already died the less threatening they
become which is kind of a problem that I
also have with K either way this credit
scene's got me so hyped and I I think I
might just be one of those morons cuz
like yeah whatever mate who cares about
the movie post credit scene saved it and
one of those clapping seals that just
claps for cameos now I'm probably not
going to do a big movie breakdown so I
thought I'd just give my thoughts on it
now in case you guys wanted to know if
you don't like your heavy spoilers being
a Critic and then this is your chance to
check out and just think about me saying
whatever you wanted me to to make you
agree with me I was really I was really
positive guys or I was very negative
depending on what you thought
unfortunately I think watching l and
then going directly into this hurt this
movie a hell of a lot though I wanted to
like it the flaws were pretty bad and I
think tonally this was all over the
place one minute you'd have a really
serious scene and the next moment you'd
have something really stupid editing
wise you can also tell I cut a lot out
too and it just means that there's
little to know character development I'm
going to give it another go when I've
had a break you know get some distance
from Loki but the movie is clearly being
cut and reshot to to try and form
something coherent Dar Ben she might be
up there as being one of the worst MCU
villains too and she's in line with the
weakest ones from Phase 2 everything is
just seen seen seen and instead of
giving us moments to see the characters
in her thoughts and feelings we just
jump from one place to the next and
forget about all that that's just
happened felt like the whole thing rush
you things as quickly as possible to get
to the ending teas cuz they wanted to B
they wanted to basically say like look
there's good stuff coming mate don't
judge it all on this however I wish they
just made the flashback it's a movie and
then I feel this would have felt more
impactful I think this 60% on rotto mod
AKA is 6 out of 10 rating that's pretty
fair and though it's not the worst MCU
movie I wouldn't put it anywhere near
the top I think this film's indicative
of all the issues there has been with
phase five where we're just getting
content for content's sake rather than
feeling a story needed to be told you
can definitely tell F he hasn't really
been supervising this stuff like he used
to as Fury from Secret invasions like a
completely different person this would
be like if Tony watched Spider-Man D his
arms at the end of infinity war and then
showed up immediately but busting out
jokes man's just lost Talos and Maria
Hill nearly caused World War III and
messed up fting the Scrolls at home they
need to start telling their directors
what's going on in projects cuz when it
comes down to this you know you cannot
watch this show and then go into this
movie also think right I think the MCU
is good at doing jokes but I don't think
that it's good at doing comedy does that
make sense I said they're good at doing
jokes you know little quips but they
can't do comedy and you can tell when
they've written entire scenes trying to
be funny it just feels like SNL skit so
yeah in the end you know I'm going to
give it another chance and try and watch
it without one of the best MCU things
hanging over my head Al maybe the movie
maybe it just isn't for me you know what
I mean um like I want to see stuff where
Tony star gets shot at and just manages
to stop the bullet because he's wearing
an Iron Man glove you know what I mean
that kind of stuff either way this
wasn't the type of thing I like tonally
but I I'll give it another go and see
how I get on Al I hate moaning to you
guys as well cuz I know you hate it too
I just have to be honest with how I felt
on the film still out that final scene
was clapping away clapping like a seal
now drop your thoughts below am I a
clapping seal did you do it too I'd
really love to hear and also if you want
to support the channel as a member of
the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you'll get early access
to videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out you want to
get some heavy spoilers merch we've also
got our t-shirt line located below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like our Theory time one
house of dragon stuff Marvel teas and a
lot more we drop new designs on there
all the time too so definitely keep an
eye out for them and thank you if you
bought one now if you want something
else to watch we've got a video on
screen right now so definitely head over
there right after this by the way huge
thank you for sing through the video
I've been Paul you take care yourself
and I'll see you next time
peace